one minute for each player
play commences now
[Music]
defending he's slow actual dog water
take
attacking
can you guys take me off can you take me
off choice.com
can you take me off the website
take me off the website get me off
[Music]
i could still win i could still win
okay
is he doing
[Music]
what
jesus
[Music]
i had too much time to think 30 seconds
all raw reactions
[Music]
oh my god oh my god what is he doing
oh god
thank you
what
[Music]
mr beast
are they not are they not switching it
off i was hoping i had good timing
my the only thing i got going for me is
timing you're supposed to switch off
why we there's no timing if it's still
on me
just saw comments you're my man cuts
like an ad or something
i get i don't have anything now
hey guys um
make sure to twitch prime or something
tonight i hope you're all having a good
day today
have you checked your balls